and now it's time for bumming reviews
with Chester a bum
tonight's review the unga games
oh my greatest movie I've ever seen in
my life
spoilers you see school ooh wait a
minute this is reviews Hunger Games
right let's do it right that's more like
it
here's this girl who has a sister who's
gonna be thrown into the Hunger Games
The Hunger Games that's what I put every
day but then her sister campus is like
are you sure you know what you're
getting yourself into Hunger Games is a
cooking show right no it's a tournament
where children kill children should I
make my special event Jane Eyre so cat
piss comes across this boy who was also
chosen and the boy is like would it be
banned if I said I had the hots for you
yes well I'm gonna die in a few days so
girlie five so worth it so The Hunger
Games is sort of like American Idol
except for killing people instead of
killing your brain cells and they're
given a mentor played by Willie
Harrelson ah drunk you're dead we have
nothing to discuss
you're a jerk I thank you so woody
harrelson teaches them how to be good
celebrities hey here's a good start make
some you add to but then when the actual
hunger game starts everybody in the
audience was just getting sick oh not
because of the greenness of children
killing children but because I care
about was shaking so much did I mention
I saw this on 9x fake mistake so a bunch
of the kids get together and form an
alliance dude we're totally gonna kill
each other later yeah whoo it just
wanted becoming good friends with you
yeah I suppose I could do something
smart like slit your throats in the
middle of a night let you sleep no
really I'm gonna slit your throat of the
night wasting yeah it's awesome
I think it's starting to sink in just
how barbaric this all this it's okay
just imagine you watch transformers 3
and all hope of caring for your fellow
man will disappear o be replaced with
testosterone fill mindlessness so the
boy that really liked campus joins their
alliance and campus is like why are you
chasing me up a tree it's okay I'm
saving your life by joining their
alliance stop ain't no better than the
trust the boy you clearly announce to
the world that he loves me well they
just watch transformers 3 so oh yeah but
this little girl named drew starts to
help cap
a trip this is like aren't you the most
adorable thing I did I guess you are
and although the world is upset that
Roux is dead after all these years of
watching kids constantly can kill me
finally have enough - it's taking the
twelve thousand kid to make it happen
but down our angry so some of the
districts start rising up and giving
really mad so hunger games are like
kooky it's totally cool if two of you
win instead of one could he possibly
mean me in the box
especially camtasia in the blackboard
series we suddenly change their minds
again Jimmy J what God that way you'll
have no winner wait
you passed the eating poisonous berries
that's totally screwing us over test you
in the Hunger Games seem to be over in
cap pants and the blonde boy go home but
the guy in charge of everything is like
I'm gonna go find the sequel yeah and I
have to say this movie was a really
exciting movie I never knew killing
children could be such an exciting sport
it's not like the game I invented called
rat fighting a bunch of rats fight each
other and the winner doesn't get eaten
by me hit there is yet to be a winner
this is just to read bumsang will yeah
can I change tomorrow huh make the next
movie if a bunch of people decide not to
make the food does that make it a hunger
strike